hey what's up welcome back to css3 in 30
days this is day number 6 Culp's print
specific styles jump over here in my
browser print specific stars what we're
gonna be doing is creating a print
specific style sheet using media queries
in CSS so that when you hit print in
your browser when you print a web page
you know you can do that you can
actually style the print stylesheet so
that when you are printing out like a
graphic heavy or a colorful you know web
page like this one for example you don't
get all of the colors and all the
backgrounds and the borders and all of
the web´s specific styles you don't want
to see that on a piece of paper because
it doesn't it won't show up or you waste
a ton of ink so you can style that that
print specific style sheet so that it
looks great so let me show you the
example so here is print specific styles
if I go ahead and hit command P to print
this you can see the preview look at how
a nice that looks it's all black and
black and white there's no backgrounds
there's no colors or images and we've
got a little bit of color here on the
links but check this out as well so all
the things like you know the the
graphics and the 3d you know text and
all that stuff that's gone and it's
replaced with something very minimal and
readable and things like the rotations
on the heading that's fixed that's all
straightened out and check this out
right after a link it actually shows the
URL because in the on the web you can
say click this link and have it be
linked up in HTML and you don't have to
see the URL you just click it because
it's interactive but on a piece of paper
it's not interactive you can't click it
you need to know what the URL is so you
can actually display that and I'll show
you how to do that in a moment
so very very simple it's just a single
page and you can print that out and it
would actually look quite nice so why
don't we jump in and do that head over
here to your code editor I'm using Adam
and I opened up my number 6 print styles
it has the index sandbox and final CSS
for your reference and enjoyment go
ahead and download those print styles
the course files for today that is in
this module you can go ahead click that
module lesson you just get the idea by
now you should know how to do that so
number six print styles we're gonna jump
straight into the sandbox and start
coding it up this is gonna be a pretty
straightforward lesson so let's go ahead
and do that so first thing you need to
do is you need to do a media query and
you know when you're doing uh you know
media queries you can do things like
screen and you know max width you know
nine hundred pixels that's gonna style
screens like your iPhone or your
computer at a maximum of nine hundred
pixels so this is how you do like a
media query for a responsive styles but
we're not doing responsive styles we're
actually doing media print so you can do
a print style sheet so we're gonna style
everything within these parentheses here
so let's go ahead and first things first
let's hide some unwanted elements and
I'm just gonna bang through them here so
we're gonna hide course files is the is
the button that says download course
files the big blue button we're gonna
hide that I'm gonna go comma what else
we're gonna hide we're gonna hide the
logo which is in the footer we're gonna
hide the sandbox before so now you know
I'll show you what I'm doing here if I
go to the index file
I'm hiding the course files because I
don't want to see that this you're not
gonna need to click that on a piece of
paper the things like the oh let me find
it here sandbox actually the sandbox
isn't even in this specific lesson we're
just using final so final dash result
before so if I go to my index here the
final result
we're actually styling something in the
theme styles called before so if I go
over to here to my browser and show you
you know how we did this 3d sort of
effect here if I inspect this and show
you basically this is what that looks
like here we've got final result before
so we styled that to have that you know
sort of 3d element we don't want to see
that in a print stylesheet so I'm hiding
that so I'm go back to CS
so final result before we're also going
to copy that
another comma and info before because we
did the same effect there and final
result after we also have that same
style going on there the after
pseudo-element
and info after
what else do we have here I believe
we're gonna hide the images I don't want
to see any images and I'm just going to
say display:none
all gone just like that now nah
basically maybe let's go check it out
Prince alright so okay so everything is
showing up for me because what's
happening is we're hooking in the final
duck CSS but we're trying to sell the
sandbox so here go back to our code
editor here in your index if you want to
hide the final result all you're gonna
have to do here is final project CSS
used for reference just comment that out
if you want to hide the print styles so
I'm even just put a comment here
so yeah comment this out if you want to
hide the final styles so now let's go
back to our browser if I hit refresh and
then print command P I will see there we
go
so it's everything's still kind of
styled in a in a basic way there some
browsers will automatically remove
things like backgrounds if I go to more
settings I can like you know I can
adjust the margins I can leave the
headers and the backgrounds on the
graphic so if I left that in basically
it's just styling the web page as you
can see that so let's go back here to
our code editor in sandbox let's
continue and now let's do the I'm gonna
call this the global typography reset
and comment that make a comment there
okay and now in the global typography
reset what we're gonna do is we're just
gonna select body and we're gonna say
font family I want to make it George
Georgia is a nice Georgia and serif is
people like reading serif typically on
paper you read serif typefaces like in
books whereas on the web sans serif is a
pretty good fun I mean obviously you can
there's no hard and fast rules but serif
fonts are nice to read on paper so
Georgia has a good one font size we're
gonna say 16 point which was kind of
more of a print based measurement set of
pixels because we're not really using
pixels on paper there's no pixels on
paper so we're gonna use points line
height we're gonna say 24 points
background no backgrounds and then the
color straight up flat black I'm gonna
say that let's keep going before where
you view it let's do a layout reset
and I'm gonna say final result info
these are all classes by the way class
info and then a section html5 element
and footer we're gonna say width 100%
because they have specific widths
currently border no borders padding:0
margin:0 and color triple zero as well
because some of those elements have
different colors so save that now let's
view it and see what it looks like
refresh command P to view alright so you
could see that we're getting there it's
pretty messy I mean if I use the default
settings here and I just turned off
background graphics then you can kind of
see that it's already looking okay but
let's leave that on so that we have to
override it alright let's keep going
let's go down to the keep going into
section the layout reset here we're
going to say section first child before
that is a top border on the instructor
that the end the section that says
instructions I want to hide that I'm
gonna say border none save that and now
let me save that and check it out in the
browser let me see what we have so far
see if we were missing any sort of
global styling okay so I don't want any
backgrounds you know this stuff is hard
to see I don't want to see that big logo
up at the top I don't want any of these
backgrounds so let's go back to the code
editor and remove the backgrounds in
these sections and remove this
background logo so I want to hide this I
believe it's in body in before so body
before we want to remove that element
altogether and what do we have the
backgrounds and final result
yeah backgrounds and sandbox fondant
result info so go back here in layout
reset I want to add background none
and in fact background:none is in there
as well great so now body right after
the global typography reset I'm actually
just gonna change this to say global
reset and then body pseudo-element
before display:none and let's actually
move body before up to the to the hide
unwanted elements so we don't even let's
just do it right at the very top body
before comma save that now let's see hit
print
all right we're getting there we're
getting there what else I want to hide I
want to hide these tabs I don't want
these tabs here so what are those those
are final result I believe those are h2s
so we got body a final result h2 yes I
don't actually want to see those let's
hide that as well
so let's go final result h2 and info h2
save that should solve the problem let's
uh let's have a look there we go those
are gone so we're getting there you
start to see that this is looking a
little bit more like it needs to not
perfect but let's keep going
okay down to the bottom oh we've already
done that now let's do some specifics so
I'm gonna say specifics
and we're gonna say H one two three four
five and six and we're gonna straight-up
say color triple zero to override any
styles their font size 24 points line
height give it some line height of 30
points and margin no margins and now
let's do even more specific we're gonna
say h1 we're gonna style that one to the
font size 50 points margin:0 0 20 points
text-align:center width 100 percent
transform roast transform rotate 0
because it's currently on a rotating we
don't want to see that and then let's
style the small h1 h1 small tag within
there we're gonna say font size 24
points we're gonna say color triple 8 a
little bit lighter than black margin:0 0
10 points okay and let's save that and
check it out one more time over here
refresh hit print what do we got looking
better already de 6 print specific
styles the small is right there this is
large they got margins at center beauty
beauty beauty all right now do we got so
let's go back here to this to the style
sheets and box right after h1 small
let's go ahead and select the a link we
want these links to be to have no
margins and let's do a after
pseudo-element this is where we're gonna
add the text of the URL so this is how
we do that we say content and then we
open some strings here and in that first
string set of strings a space and then a
square open square bracket outside of
the string attribute we're gonna select
the href
and then a space after that open and
close another set of strings and then
close the square bracket and then close
to the semicolon and then let's just do
one last thing here we're gonna say
footer a link and footer a visited
we're gonna go color triple zero and
then background none save that let's go
over here refresh hit print see what
we've got this is looking pretty good I
see there's some weird padding around
this link and I know that we had padding
cuz we had those little pop-up boxes in
the footer and this text is too grey I
want it to not be grey I want it to be
black so let's go here we're gonna say
padding:0 in fact in all the links we're
just gonna say padding:0 maybe that will
solve the problem then I want the text
within all of these sections color 0 I'm
just gonna say important on that to
override any styles let's see what we've
got a fresh print okay so the the
padding on the links didn't change and
that didn't change alright let's find
out why so I'm going to select this
inspect it
and I'm going to what do we got footer a
link padding so I'm gonna have to over
be more specific there yep and this text
why is it non overriding info P okay go
back over here I'm gonna actually change
this remove that and I'm going to say
down here under h1 small I'm gonna say
info P and I'm gonna say color triple
zero and this should this should be
padding:0 and a link doesn't need
padding that should do it
save head over to the browser do a
refresh and a print and we should have
our final print specific style so now if
I change here in the settings and your
backgrounds or graphics it should really
just all its modifying is the day number
six it's wants it to be darker which is
fair in fact why don't we just change
that right now let's go h1 small let's
just change this to triple zero and that
should do it back to the browser refresh
print and there we go we've got our
print specific style sheet if I change
these settings now it really shouldn't
do anything at all beautiful those are
the print specific styles great work now
what you can do is you could take these
styles add them to your own websites
your own blogs applications client sites
whatever it is and just go to any random
page and hit command P and print go to
print it out and see what the preview
looks like and you can see if they have
a style sheet for print or not and on
your own websites you can go ahead and
add some print style sheets so that if
for some crazy reason your grandfather
wants to print out your website he'll be
able to read it properly on his good
old-fashioned piece of paper
[Music]